[Music]
so no one told you life was
[Music]
it's like you're always stuck in second
gear
when
[Music]
you like i've been there before i'll be
there for you
cause you're there for me too
[Music]
so far things are going great
your mother warned you there'll be
[Music]
[Music]
when the rain starts before i'll be
there for you
like i've been there before i'll be
there for you
cause you're there for me too
no one could ever know me
no one could ever see me
since you're the only one who knows
what it's like to be me someone to face
the day with
make it through all the recipes
[Music]
it's like you're always stuck in second
gear
when it hasn't been your day
[Music]
when the rain starts to
i've been there before i'll be there for
you
cause you're there for me
about one year ago october 9th 2020 is
when the channel was named theories of
everything and almost exactly one year
later it's now at 100 000 subscribers
and we didn't start at zero but either
way thank you
thank you so much for
watching for listening for
re-watching re-listening for engaging in
the comments for donating for engaging
on reddit for sharing online offline
thank you
thank you so much there's no sponsor
message for this
simply
just
a thank you for what has been
accomplished also i'd like to thank
reddit user not my account for choosing
the clips and editing this video as well
as ryan demelle a singer an artist who
allowed for the usage of this song his
cover and the links to his work are in
the description
think
not my account and thank ryan and thank
you